it's it was it is a sort of little-known
thing I didn't but you are a recording
artist oh dear oh well I let's say I've
been forced into the studio at gunpoint
on occasion yes yes yeah no you went all
kind of hip-hop
rappy honors didn't you yes I have I
have a I haven't a rap hit that haunts
me for the rest of my days yes yes this
was you and and Danny Aykroyd word we
were promoting dragnet a motion picture
1987 and we sang of course everybody can
sing along
lookout streebek you're just in time we
have stumbled into a major crime she's
got the girlfriend now that's not nice I
think he is a subject of a sacrifice
buddy this party on ice but first you
know we really ought to read them their
rights read them their rights Whedon
they're right
it was choreographed by Paula Abdul
believe it or not choreographed by Paula
Abdul and it it was a mercy but it was
the first thing I'd ever seen on YouTube
because my kids were asking about it one
day and I said dad we got to see this
stupid thing where is it as it all it's
on a VHS tape somewhere buried in the
basement and they pulled that YouTube
very quick and there it was so my kids
now can torture me with this thing
we're now recording Toy Story 4 so we
were doing that it'll be able to 3,000
apt as a matter of fact so it takes a
long time